this podcast is brought to you by better
help now if you're a genius brain
listener you know I've talked about
better help a lot and you've heard it on
many podcasts but I am somebody who
actually does use better help whenever I
need somebody to talk to listen I've
worked on my mental health for many
years now and better help has been by my
side because whenever I need to access
my therapist better help allows me to
access him whenever I need and I gotta
tell you I don't like in-person therapy
as much because I like doing things from
the comfort of my home I'm super busy
and instead of having to set a time a
day to drive I don't know like an hour
or so to a therapist and then drive all
the way back in traffic I have the power
in my hands I can do it all online if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge so if
you want to be like me and you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
genius today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp help.com genius
[Music]
Equinox said that they don't believe in
January workout people so essentially
what they're saying is they're not going
to accept any new memberships in January
which for me doesn't make sense number
one marketing wise stupid yeah because
just for a business sense right you want
to take new memberships because month
from people who won't work out at your
gym because your gym will stay at full
capacity but you'll still Rack in more
dollars than what you can contain it's
like the Planet Fitness model dude
that's gonna be a crazy let's be feeling
hot
[Laughter]
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we already
started drinking and Pat hasn't jacked
off at all 16 days yes
arms spaghetti you are spaghetti balls
heavy hot hot balls so why did you stop
jacking off
bro everybody wants to know I need you
to take a break dude and honestly I
didn't like the fact that I I like I
wanted it was like a discipline thing I
wanted the discipline of being able to
be like yo don't jerk off for 30 days
and then actually not doing it because I
before told you you said it out loud
I've said it huh you said it out loud
before to yourself yeah I've been like
I'm not gonna draw off three days and
then 30 minutes later I was jerking off
like I was like I'm a piece of [ __ ] so
now it's like [ __ ] that so I got some
people on board some guys that I work
with and so now I made it a competitive
thing and that's what's actually helped
me what's the stakes the trade-off is
that he becomes an abusive father
he's just mad at everybody because I
have a rubber again shut the [ __ ] up
daddy hasn't jacked off in 11 days you
know how hard this is
my balls are heavy they're heavy they're
heavy but you know hey man [ __ ] it you
know I'm being a bad dad well what's his
chicks though what's the steaks the
steaks are there well we all put 20
bucks in but it's really just a shame
thing it's just like medium yeah 20
bucks dude if you're gonna go out though
you might as well go out on day one you
know what I mean that's what I'm saying
once I got past day one I was like all
right that was the time to quit yeah
yeah because it's like what the [ __ ]
that's the hardest thing let me ask you
this though for both of you how often do
you jack off to the point where it's
like okay maybe I shouldn't jack off so
much I was jacking off like
once a day at least dude is that pretty
average a day I feel like a lot of dudes
that's pretty average I think it depends
bro sometimes like you you get stuck
where you're like busy and like doing
stuff and then sometimes you forget to
jerk off see that's why you are a
quitter if I'm not home if I'm not home
a lot I don't jack off yeah well that I
hope
what are you talking about listen listen
if I'm at the grocery store sometimes
I'm like look at that yeah yeah those
Mills look great in the bathroom obvious
statement listen if I'm not at home I
don't check it off hey but you know that
there's some people out there that like
jack off in random places I hope yeah
that's not you though come on yeah you
think I am a crazy person maybe I don't
know sometimes when when the moment hits
you it hits you so you gotta [ __ ]
when I was at me when I was a kid I used
to uh I was working at my parents store
and you know you're young and your dick
just be getting hard for no reason for
no reason so occasionally fine ass
[ __ ] lady would walk through she
would ask for some products I would be
like excuse me it's in the back I would
jack off so furiously in the back so I
could focus yeah oh yeah because clearly
she's trying to flirt with me to steal
some [ __ ] you got to re-center your
channel and we would get so much stuff
stolen because it's a bathroom jerk
because I couldn't focus but see that's
like a righteous jerk off that's like a
jerk off to get your chakras in line and
like to be focused I'm trying to be
better at my job so I need to bust this
[ __ ] nut you know what I mean that's
you're doing it for the for the
community yeah what is the biggest
change that you feel I feel what I like
is the discipline muscle so like what
I've noticed is by just constantly being
like no don't do that when I feel the
urge to do it it that transfers over to
other areas of my life so like if I'm
being lazy about like folding doing the
laundry for example that's just a small
example and I'll be like I'll do it in
an hour it's like nah I just [ __ ] do
it right now so I can quickly I can
quickly access that like override the
laziness or or aspect of being like
trying to push things away I can just
override that real quick because I'm
already working that muscle up so I'm
kind of in the mode to be like no I'm
just gonna [ __ ] do it that's the
thing I like a lot and then also too I'm
not wasting as much time
you beat off for a [ __ ] long ass I'm
a scrapbooker I forgot about what it was
like how long does that it takes this
[ __ ] writing pros and poetry
I have a menu dude it's of course that
yeah
I will watch xvideos.com
well the appetizer little PornHub and
then I'll go into Japanese porn for the
main course
a little fluff a little squeaky I enjoy
it
that's true yes are you what a gentleman
dude oh you know you know and then I
said knocks for gentlemen
so I was doing fine dining jerking off
and then I realized like dude I started
thinking about how much time I was
literally just like you're just a monkey
that's like like you know I mean like
can I climb in the nervous system yeah
no there's nothing wrong with it but
like I started adding up the time and I
was like what's that what's the close
duration
I don't I don't know sometimes it
depends but you said you added up the
time no I mean like like it looks
sometimes 30 minutes like if you do 30
minutes yeah yeah like or like 45 but
that nut was good though hey it was it
was like it was like
dude Patrick's grabbing sheets like oh
[ __ ] my baby grabbed the sheets
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bro it really was like that
laughs dude it was like my soul would
leave my body a little bit you know dude
I've never jacked off for 45 [ __ ]
minutes I should try it if I
think you made the case bro hey I'm like
dude that's not productive but I think
you made the case hey I'm gonna [ __ ]
whine and dine myself if you got 45
minutes to spare yeah you wanna yeah
treat yourself
so I don't know what you can do it 45
minutes it's pretty quick yeah it's like
the image is there I got it I whack it
off and I'm done and I could focus yeah
you're proficient yeah you're in a fit
you're yeah you're you're uh uh like you
do it for utility but what the [ __ ]
takes 45 [ __ ] minutes the curation
bro no it's not the Cure no no it's just
it's just it's what it is is like so
this is what you do this is what you do
okay I feel like we've been through this
but I'm gonna get a little synopsis a
quick little brief so I I told you guys
about the moose bouge I I do that I do I
do I do I do the tiered thing right I do
the openers like those are the the
appetizers some main courses and then
you get the finishers you could tell
right off the bat sometimes where
there's like a a video where it's like
that's a finisher yeah yeah yeah and
then you put the tab and you move it
over there yeah yeah yeah I'm like these
are finished as I left those off so I
kind of like Get I worked my way up to
the finishers can I ask you something go
ahead before you go like what what are
some qualities of a video that
constitutes a finisher it's not so much
about the video it's about the honestly
the girl like there's you know porn
stars that I fancy more than yeah you
know you got a fat old booty I'm
interested I like that you know and
that's like okay
finisher pile also two angles sometimes
the camera work like some camera work is
whack or whatever and I'm gonna show the
juice [ __ ] can I just say not real
quick
porn director out there nobody needs the
underside ball shot
is
how would you do it better ball sweat
dripping on his face how do you do that
shot
that's why they got the boom my guy he's
got goggles on he's got goggles on oh
God my back dude you know what's worse
is sometimes they get avant-garde and
then they wanna they wanna show the
dude's face when he's coming
back worst thing ever it's you see it
again
this girl's getting smashed from the
back and you enjoy it like that's
[ __ ] nice then all of a sudden
that's good that's amazing all of a
sudden you see this [ __ ] Romanian
coin
sacks for a couple of shackles
got his foot all the way up exactly both
feet on the wall like a spider dude he's
defying the laws of physics
it's getting to the best part it goes to
his face
like what the [ __ ] that's the guy from
Eastern Europe
where is that I've literally been like
at the point where I was about to come
and then they span of the guy's face and
now I'm coming but laughing yeah this
guy's fake he's like oh and I'm like now
I'm coming to this guys what are the
dudes together why are you guys doing
that to me oh he's in sync now I'm
sexually confused to blur his face don't
show me his face a majority of porn
consumers are men blur the [ __ ] face
95 for sure yeah show me the face ever
yeah don't want to see his face how long
for you
dude quick bro like maybe five minutes
tops in and out same here the thing is
is like I wish I I can do that too but
the thing is it feels so much better
when you prolong it for a little bit
it's just like the nut is I'm telling
you it's better we're missing I'm
missing out because honestly I can't
imagine jacking off for 45 minutes I
know your web browser tab is all dots
you're like which one is this one you
just have to guess in the middle which
one if you're gonna be really organized
one no I have a whiteboard and I have
like the minute marks I'd be like 32
yeah the red lines that attached to the
other one yeah
it's like a crime scene it's like a True
Detective season one but with just a fat
ass in the middle of the bubble and like
all the connecting dots how do we get
back to the finisher the finish so
what's like an opening course what would
you constitute opening course video like
I said it just it doesn't it's not
necessarily like a genre or type or
anything it just depends on like it's
okay so so what is it mostly so it's
like this is what I'm saying like it's
it's something where I'm like kind of
interested like a little interested like
I'm not like I'm not I know that like
I'm not super in on that I could I could
skip it yeah but there's something about
it that caught my eye yeah
good thumbnail good presentation you
could tell the guys that they're good
writing you know they put good work into
it the music is like yes the great
dialogue well I never had a black [ __ ]
getting me free oh you ain't never had a
black [ __ ] before yeah my husband's
White
and he can't fill me in like you okay
and that's where I go like this damn
good writing
that's good I love this this is great I
can connect to this instrument this is
Cinema
so I just want them to stop talking I'm
like don't talk yeah no the talking is
[ __ ] terrible but you know yeah so
something I'm slightly interested and
then the next year is something where
I'm like okay it could be it could be
but it's lacking a couple things in the
slacking couple and then the finishers
are just the finishers man what is your
what is your current top porn search
right now well right now I'm not
searching any porn but the thing is is I
honestly I try to trick him and he got
me with him come on I'm not we're
abstinent dog no but no busting baby
yeah I'm so close
um yeah no nothing right now right now
I'm just trying to like I I'm just like
for the most part like I said it's cool
but there's every once in a while that's
tight that you're doing it though and
you're and you're like yo I feel better
you feel a lot better but like you feel
like you get a lot more done you're more
productive that's tight there's times
where I'm just bored and stressed I'm
like I just want to I should just nut
and I'll feel way better though but I
feel like that's what most people do
right is they just [ __ ] beat off yeah
well I mean it's ease and stress and
they're just like at home I feel like I
could do probably easy honestly no jack
off two weeks pretty easy oh bro
I think I could do that two weeks for
sure easy if as long as I just jog half
a mile you're boy pretty tired yeah I'm
pretty exhausted it's a week yeah balls
are heavy I'll tell you this straight up
when I was first losing weight
I'll store all the time and then one
time Mario looked over at me she goes
you don't want to have sex and I looked
at I was like I'm tired
so so it it hurts like sex is the last
thing I'm thinking about I'm just
exhausted when I look at her I'm horny
like I'm like yeah yeah yeah that's your
hearty faces
giving me six and then I would reach
over and yeah
touch your head like this and then she
goes yes and I go
just a little tired I had too much of
mushroom and I just turned over and I
just can't do it I can't perform yeah
really my tiredness overpowers my
horniness I feel like when things hit
you though they hit you hard
like you have like 20 milligrams of
caffeine and he's a [ __ ] owl you
can't go to sleep
[ __ ] that's what happened to me
yesterday I slept at 4am
had a nice double shot of espresso at
what time like 2 p.m bad move damn
that's rough but that's crazy that
didn't wear off from 2ps a long time no
if I have caffeine anything past like 8
A.M pretty much 8 A.M I'm pretty much
[ __ ] so you don't drink coffee what
time do you wake up I drink uh this
thing called jumbi matcha the best
matcha brand that you have ever had in
your life it has something called
l-thean and it imagines it manages your
caffeine it takes the Jitters
it's very good but um yeah I can't have
caffeine anything past like 8 A.M well I
do anyways yeah but if I don't have any
caffeine I'll sleep at 11 PM easy oh wow
but then the midday part's really hard
for me yeah they say not to do it after
3 P.M like that's like cut off or like
nine to ten hours before you go to sleep
no caffeine before five is the absolute
latest for me let me ask you all this
this is what I wanted to ask there was
actually Hot Topics but I don't give a
[ __ ] about them right now it's Hot Topic
that's what happens when I drink shut
the [ __ ] up this is what we're talking
about what are your guys I'm curious New
Year's goals oh [ __ ]
New Year's goals
let me think about them you have nice
thoughts did you write a list
do I have a right list no not really you
just got on your head I got him in the
head because you know I was thinking
about it a lot during December
um because in the fitness industry I
gotta ramp up all this stuff before
January because that's when you get like
a lot more
clients more onboarding stuff like that
but um
yeah goal for me is just try to Market
more of myself just do that more and and
how are you going to do that [ __ ] well
first I'm your boy Consulting with
somebody on my website I got a mark I'm
a talking one of my clients is a
marketing guy I'm sit down and really
have a sit down with him and I've been
chatting with the other couple like
marketing agencies
so just like get the x's and o's a
little bit and see how they would do it
for me like if I was does it scare you a
little bit oh 100 100 and I think
leaning into what scares me is like the
main theme of 2023 like it's crazy
experiences it's crazy how good [ __ ] for
you scares you for some reason what is
that about [ __ ] is that it's part of
growth and electric Kaizen and all that
[ __ ] dude hi Sand dude that's what
people say always progressing like that
[ __ ] nonsense bro but no but that's
just that a bunch of positive [ __ ] and
called a gay at the same time
that's in my head that's the voice of my
head constantly it's vitamins
[Music]
I get like that too though
it is literally the worst quality
anybody can have and we have the worst
quality when you do something positive
for yourself and your brain is like who
do you [ __ ] it makes me nervous to do
things that progress my future
me too yeah are we just [ __ ] like
somebody will give me like a hundred
dollar bill I'm like yeah right
dude [ __ ] I'm gonna take this four bro
but I I feel a lot of people kind of go
through this right and I don't know what
it is I think it's because we don't want
to be caught in our own [ __ ] right
because in our mind I feel like we talk
ourselves a big game I put so much work
into my [ __ ] and then we when we fail it
kind of reaffirms the fact that what we
really feel is that we're not worth
anything yeah it's like I [ __ ] told
you so yeah yeah you thought you were
some dope [ __ ] and then it's like you
have to fight the temptation of being
like a self-fulfilling prophecy in a
weird way of like because sometimes you
do I I think of myself like I think I am
like hyper critical in things that I do
to the point where sometimes it's like a
lot of self-doubt and then I just end up
being complacent and like not moving
forward because I'm like
sitting in the sphere kind of like what
we talked about the coffee shop yeah
yeah it's like that's a that's a huge
like Cloud over my head but I feel like
the only time and I was I felt like last
year I was like dealing with that a lot
and I think the only way I was able to
kind of like pull myself out of it was
just
just keeping myself sane by just saying
okay how can I just make everything just
a little bit better every day like just
trying my best in any possible way I
could think of and I think that's the
only thing that's been fighting the
demons off you know how to make my
my craft better how do I you know
coaching better just anything I'm doing
try to make it a little bit better I
think it's smart too when you break it
because that's the thing about goals
like that's I think a big problem that
people run into in New York New Year's
goals is they throw these things out
there but there's no practical like like
your goals like whether it's like to
make a million dollars or whatever the
[ __ ] it is there's a lot of little
practical steps you have to take every
day that that's that's the [ __ ] that
actually matters which is like though
how are you gonna do it like with the
little Lego pieces like how what are you
actually gonna [ __ ] do because anyone
could be like I want to make a million
dollars I was like okay now what though
what are you gonna do to do that so if
you focus on those little things that
actually progress you in that in that
way that's actually the right move but
then that that fear comes in that that
fear of I think part of it too is is
leaving your comfort zone even if you
don't like what your current situation
is there's still comfort in knowing what
it is yeah and like even if something's
good for you like the part of you that's
like afraid of the unknown
[ __ ] with you even though you know this
is not good for you you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so weird it
keeps you in that place that you you
expect so you're already expecting your
day-to-day routine you know what it's
like yeah so everything you're doing is
trying to keep you in iglare room trying
to keep you there you know so it's tough
so what are you gonna do this year
so this year
um I want to uh
well with comedy I definitely want to
um I want to film a special for sure and
I want to like really start uh yeah I
think I'm just gonna do it on my own
like [ __ ] it you know what I mean and I
what I need to do you'll need help stop
professional you know I'm a professional
this is what I do forever yeah thank you
baby I appreciate that I want to film up
on it though I will honestly I really
will I the Practical steps I need to
take though this is my thing like I
write like a [ __ ] I love writing
like I love writing I love getting on
stage where I the the part of writing
that I lack on is the editing process
like I I I get so excited about finding
new things and like I love getting up
there and like trying new [ __ ] and like
it's exciting and whatnot what I need to
be better at and this is what will get
me to that special is just coming home
and refining it like taking the time to
be like all right no like just focus on
this subject for a longer and and and
and hone in on the [ __ ] that you have
that's kind of like it's working but it
could be even better like that's the
writing step that I need to do yeah so
if I do that
and just put myself out there more
that's another thing too that's another
fear thing where I was like afraid to
put myself out there as much that I just
got to stop being a little [ __ ]
[Music]
this podcast is brought to you by better
help now if you're a genius brain
listener you know I've talked about
better help a lot and you've heard it on
many podcasts but I am somebody who
actually does use better help whenever I
need somebody to talk to listen I've
worked on my mental health for many
years now and better help has been by my
side because whenever I need to access
my therapist better help allows me to
access him whenever I need and I gotta
tell you I don't like in-person therapy
as much because I like doing things from
the comfort of my home I'm super busy
and instead of having to set a time a
day to drive I don't know like an hour
or so to a therapist and then drive all
the way back in traffic I have the power
in my hands I can do it all online if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge so if
you want to be like me and you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you visit betterhelp.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help help.com genius
[Music]
I mean look at Jason Cheney look at that
[ __ ] Like That Guy believes in himself
so much and I don't look in that [ __ ]
nothing between those eyes
absolutely nothing but you've been
posting more [ __ ] yeah I mean that's
part of it it's the practice of it right
yeah I'm just gonna like start doing it
yeah dude Jason has the loosest grasp of
the English language and he's out there
doing stand-up baby yeah yeah yeah
will message be some of the most
salacious [ __ ] oh yeah of all time I'll
just be chilling yeah and I'll get a
random text message hey fatty I'm like
it's 7 A.M yeah yeah dude when he hits
you with the second dinner thing I was
like that's [ __ ] up bro that fool
literally said a video of this fat
Chinese guy with his hair and honey I
think inside Davis knows Barber did a
great job
[Laughter]
[ __ ] guy
everybody thinks he's so innocent he's a
little [ __ ] dude especially over a
[ __ ] Instagram huh he'd be trying to
roast you dude all the time our our
Instagram thread if it ever gets hacked
you'll just see two people going at it
oh yeah
canceling each other no totally that's
how it was for me and him for a long
time too and we broke through this other
Zone where we're like
yeah yeah we're showing dicks now we
showed dicks now we're now we're in love
yeah yeah now we [ __ ] you haven't seen
his dick yet huh no cadaver yeah black I
told you it's black right it's the
blackest Chinese have you ever seen it's
just have you ever seen a little
Japanese boy dead in an ocean or a good
Lake it's all blue that's what it is
well this will literally walked into
like the bathroom of of the back room at
like The Comedy Store and I had no idea
what he was doing because I basically
joked around I was like show me your
dick or you're gay clearly this is a
joke yeah right you don't want to be
yeah I just see him holding his camera
running around like his Cloverfield
close to the bathroom and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this guy doing and then he
just starts slapping his dick
and forever burned in my head for the
rest of my life you didn't want to see
it and now I'm traumatized you gotta
face your abuses
listen I've been trying to assault him
back for a few days how are you gonna
get him back I sent him a picture of my
dead dick
it just says
he knows he knows the trick he's like um
what's the goal for you David so I'm
going to fix my knee
which is something that's good for me
that I've been putting off for years
meaning against surgery are you going oh
yeah there's no option it's done that
pop was ridiculous yeah because I think
as as the work that we did has gained
its Mobility back to its Max which is
pretty cool that's missing your ankle
though too yeah so I'm gonna get this
I'm beginning to get an MRI on my ankle
and this but this whole [ __ ] I gotta get
it fixed I don't have to because I can
run fine I can move fine but I want to
be dagestani bro so I need to fix this
[ __ ] because I need that Mobility yeah
um and I think if I had that it's going
to
it's gonna [ __ ] up my progression so
I'll we're gonna work early and then
towards the end of the year I'm just
going to get it done after I you know do
all the [ __ ] that I want I'm gonna get
it knocked out I heard the recovery
process is only about a month oh sorry
because it's meniscus right yeah sorry
skip step or they'll replace or do
something you'll be good to go and
that'll be good after a month so I'm
just gonna get that [ __ ] done yeah um I
think I'm kind of over
boxing and kickboxing I think I just
like it for the the fun of it I don't
care to do it in um like sparring to me
is fun right but I think that when I
started going to other gyms most people
aren't there to have fun try to knock
your ass they're trying to kill you and
I was like oh I'm kind of in this for
the homies like I just like training
yeah most people aren't like that and I
just didn't know because you know it
just wasn't the environment that you
know I had yeah so when I went to a
couple of other gyms and then people
just tried to [ __ ] knock your block
off but I'm like oh I don't think I'm a
fighter I think I just enjoy the sport
yeah and even if it's playing
recreationally exactly and so I think
being able to see other people train it
kind of put in perspective like I don't
think I like this this part is so fun to
watch isn't it yes dude I just sent him
videos of this these backyard Korean
brawls of these like country bumpkins
just boxing all look like David bro
they're all like different versions of
David not even a racial way they legit
one of the guys look like me five years
ago yeah bro but [ __ ] like different
stages of his life and his brother too
they all like his brother too so I shall
marry that video she goes I thought that
was you I was like just wait till you
fight and you know it's not me he's good
but they all kind of they have this
scowl on their face that I'm like oh
that's David that's David and uh he was
sending me this [ __ ] last night and I
was like oh that's the face he gives
when he's like about to beat up an owner
of a very famous fight shot yeah yeah
exactly
that is not true at all really nice man
I have a very sweet I have defended
myself too many times all right we don't
gotta talk about it we don't got to talk
about it all right but we all
traumatized that we shared a slice of
pizza after you traumatized that man
it's okay he still has not he wakes up
I'm sorry
honey it was the big Asian man again
okay it's okay he's a comedian he's a
comedian he makes jokes don't worry
about it he won't do it to you again he
deserved it he deserved every [ __ ]
punch to the face all right don't double
down no no no no and he's also a racist
he's tripling down when I hit him in the
face he went like this oh good shot he
didn't do that yeah did you guys see the
um I don't know this is not a Hot Topic
but I legit saw this because I did a
video where I was talking about how when
you go into like the gym in the first
week everybody looks at you as if you're
not supposed to be there because they
legit look at you like oh you're gonna
be gone in a couple of weeks and I don't
like that and that Equinox thing came
out right like the day after I posted
that which I didn't understand the
purpose of their marketing what was it
what was it so Equinox said that they
don't believe in January workout people
so essentially what they're saying is
they're not going to accept any new
memberships in January which for me
doesn't make sense number one marketing
wise stupid yeah because just for a
business sense is right you want to take
new memberships because month from
people who won't work out at your gym
because your gym will stay at full
capacity but you'll still Rack in more
dollars than what you can contain it's
like the Planet Fitness model exactly
you want their whole model is they don't
want people that actively work out in
their gym so they take out the barbells
they say no slamming weights if you wear
like it's a safe space they give Pizza
yeah they give pizzas so they want
people that don't work out so then
they're just constantly on auto pay sure
and then they don't have wear and tear
on the gym equipment so it's like kind
of a win-win but I guess that's kind of
what you know what you're alluding to
that's what Equinox that's [ __ ] dumb
though but the stuff why I turn down all
that money we did the story on JK and
apparently I thought it was the whole
month of January but it was apparently
like not January 1st that's the only day
of the month oh who knows if they like
yeah attracted or something like that
but it's still like just dumb because
like Equinox is so like the fitness
industry has his nose up and everybody
anyway like most people that's not I
think a lot of people that don't work
out is because they're they don't like
the whole like I'm better than you
because I I grind harder than you every
day yeah you know like those like those
gym goers they're annoying we all know
those people and they turn it off for a
lot and number one nobody goes to
Equinox to work out nobody goes to
[ __ ] Equinox to work out is 200
[ __ ] dollars a month you try 300 bro
okay it's 300 now 300 okay that's crazy
so it's 300 a month right on top of that
when I went to Equinox one time on a
guest pass nobody was working out yeah
dude everybody was sitting around doing
nothing they were doing jack all [ __ ]
that's the best lotions though the pumps
dude they had towels everything laundry
service laundry service here's the thing
they're the only people who go to
Equinox in LA are number one gay dudes
all my gay people shout outs to you you
know what's up it's a gays cause they
looking for the zaddies right
all the gay homies say that that's where
you find like closet gay dudes that want
to [ __ ] number two gay homies told me
yeah now another everywhere number two
is girls looking for Rich guys to date
like NBA players like stars and [ __ ] so
nobody goes to Equinox to get their
[ __ ] Fitness on shut the [ __ ] up that
makes no sense that's not even your
business model you cost 300 a month yeah
also too you know who needs to work out
the most fat people
yeah bro
yeah yeah you know that's happy when I
see a fat person in the gym hell yeah
hell yeah yeah
guess what US fat people hate you yeah
and then you do this and I go yeah [ __ ]
you guys
stop that [ __ ] hey man stop making fun
of me I'm supporting dude I hate it when
I'm in the gym and another fat person
looks at me and they go hey man you too
I'm like no we're not in the same room
don't touch me and get the [ __ ] out of
here fatty all right it's January 1st
you don't belong
fatty don't you dare look at me and give
me this right here put your [ __ ]
chicken wings down you fat [ __ ] I am not
you bro you can't be fan shaming people
on the internet fat still so I can fat
shame whoever is he fat yeah you're not
fat
that's a nice titty all right I could do
that too with my tip bro no no no no no
no no I I'm still fat no okay no no
don't I don't take this power away from
me you're not fat bro I feel like I
think you should be a lot of fashion
immune if you're not fat
let's go let's go the moment I stop
being fat I will still continue to
Fashion yeah yeah you're like I used to
be fat yeah I will go even harder you
can say that yeah yeah skinny [ __ ]
listen you're skinny dog I don't think
that there is ever a problem for a
former fat person to talk [ __ ] uh make
fat jokes because I know the pain yeah I
know what it's like to walk in and say
oh look at David he's sitting next to
everybody yeah
yeah
I love it it is great yeah so but these
fat jokes would be so [ __ ] up because
I remember growing up like you would try
to roast your friends and they would say
a fat joke and the whole time I'm trying
not to laugh because if I laugh I lose
yeah so they'll just I don't know
they'll say something and then
everybody's cracking up and I gotta be
like like this oh yeah but in my mind
I'm like
these jokes are so tried and true like
they've never failed they're like the
Workhorse you know what I mean they're
like the the whatever the wheat industry
in this country that gives you the bread
like it's just always there they're
consistent Dependable like that joke you
just said funny dude every time every
time yeah
bread that's bread right there I can
always depend on bread I remember
freaking uh I wonder when um Aries
Spears made that joke about lizzo so
Aries when Aries Spears who's I [ __ ]
love he's like one of my favorite style
Comics he's so funny and he made a
comment basically saying lizzo looks
like the [ __ ] Emoji
it's a quick joke so I was like okay
that means yeah yeah I was kind of
unnecessary like out of nowhere yeah the
weird and people went [ __ ] in on him
because you know he hiki looks like the
[ __ ] Emoji himself so people were
basically making fun of him is like how
can you make fun of a fat person when
you're [ __ ] fat too
and so the internet tore his ass up dude
that's so they went in on him because of
the body positivity thing yeah but the
funny thing I don't know if lizzo has
ever said that she was healthy
so I don't understand what the big deal
it's not like she's ever said like I'm
healthy she plays the flu hella good hey
music is dope so do you guys ever watch
kill Tony yes so Tiffany's been watching
it out of random like she just starts
watching it because she loves it now so
then she kind of put me onto it you know
who David Lucas is dude bro David
so that's what I'm gonna bring up Tony
who's Cliff had a really good joke and
he he goes into fat jokes on David Lucas
and then David Lucas always go on calls
Tony hitchcliff gay or something yeah
yeah Tony Hinchcliffe looks at [ __ ]
David Lucas and he goes do you look like
lizzo's fitness trainer and I was like
damn that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] hella
funny because he looked like you know
Mark Norman had a roast for [ __ ] uh
David Lucas oh yes
one of them I remember was like so David
Lucas does his minute set and he turns
around he starts praising Mark Normandy
he's like Mark Norman like I [ __ ] with
you you're funny and he's like haha
thank you and he's like NWA too much
comedy personally but yeah Mark Norman I
don't there's so many in that club it's
almost too fast he's too fast too hard
to roast it's too quick he's too quick
he's the fastest dude I've ever seen in
my entire seriously I just hit him on
the Rogan podcast he says so many jokes
it's hard to catch him because he's that
fast yeah and I have to pause and Rewind
and go back yeah and then hear these
jokes again yeah like how do you think
that quick he's definitely on the
Spectrum yeah for sure he's going he's
like the rain man of jokes he really is
he goes he's volume oh I remember after
that roast he calls him NWA too much and
then David Lucas goes like you look like
somebody who I would have stole your
lunch money and he goes yeah I could
tell he's like yeah he's like yeah you
did yeah
yeah it goes and then David Lucas is
dying laughing and that that [ __ ] is
hard to roast somebody for 10 minutes
straight oh yeah and do it every week
and also fast like it's like no thoughts
in between if I had to do that kill Tony
[ __ ] I'd probably survive three four
jokes and then that's it yeah and then
it's just me sitting going uh uh uh you
know yeah they're good
like a good amount of them because
they're good jokes yeah they're so hard
to do that and be original only on those
two topics of being gay and then being
fat like that's so hard for 10 minutes
yeah bro do you do that she's in the
pocket bro when David and Lucas first
came out and he did that he destroyed
Tony Hinchcliffe he wasn't even
expecting him and then Tony came back
ready yeah he went back and forth I was
like oh now it's a little even yeah yeah
yeah but sometimes it depends sometimes
David Lucas gets the better of them
sometimes Tony because I watch all those
clips and it's like they're usually
pretty even but both those fools are so
good so good at roasting yeah David
Lucas is a [ __ ] animal dude uh did
you see the one with when Bill Burr came
out oh and got mad at Tony Hinchcliffe
yeah billboard just [ __ ] obliterated
yeah yeah yeah he goes what the [ __ ] is
your
problems everybody dude he defends
everybody on my damn billboard is not
somebody should have up here he'll kill
he'll just rip into you he'll rip in you
like to your soul
oh [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] up dude and then
the one with Theo bond is really funny
too because he just like apologizes the
whole time yeah yeah you're like rip on
somebody like I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't mean to say that like it's pretty
hard for you to be up here yeah it's
just such a nice dude bro when uh Bill
Burr was on uh the Rogan podcast
watching him kind of go toe-to-toe with
Rogan oh dude he was kind of dunking on
Rogan dude and the Rogue is crying
laughing yeah just because of how good
his responses are dude how do you do
that he's he's so and it's just like who
he is it's not even like it's not he's
not even trying it's just that's just
who he is yeah Bill Burr is a [ __ ]
animal I just saw Lucy K on Theo Von's
podcast today that [ __ ] was amazing dude
really yeah very good Tiff was watching
today it was good you're watching all
that [ __ ] it's crazy because a Theo
doesn't do the um the Brendan shot
podcast anymore yeah he's it's done yeah
yeah he's not a part of the the anything
no the king of the sting is like he's
out
he's talking about that huh what'd you
think about that I just was surprised
because they were doing really well well
doesn't he like not live in LA anymore
oh yeah I heard he lives out in like
Louisiana and just flies in oh yeah or
some [ __ ] yeah yeah bro that's hard to
do yeah
because he has his own podcast that he
does yeah that's the one that he had
with Louis on that came out today it's
just [ __ ] amazing yeah I was kind of
shocked because I was looking at it and
it's
um King no it's not the it's the king
the sting and something it sounds like
Chris Delia and Eric Griffin or
something oh they probably rebranded I
don't know what's going on yeah I don't
even know what's happening Brenda Schaub
or any of that [ __ ] I just know you
hate him but that's cool
[Laughter]
dude I didn't even hear Ariel's stuff I
just kind of recapped what happened yeah
but apparently he [ __ ] slapped the [ __ ]
out of his wife right twice it was crazy
but she slapped him first though she did
slap him first so everybody was saying
listen first slap you would have been
clear yeah you know because he kept
following up it was Tit for Tat that he
would Tit for Tat for blip you don't go
twice you know man once it's like you
made your point the second one is like I
want you to wake up tomorrow bro if you
got something to lose and you're Dana
White dude and you slap your wife that's
it but the way you're in the coffin
what's crazy is he's not done so he he
like I mean he came out and said what he
said yeah and then it's just he's still
like I was watching there was a clip of
him getting interviewed by people and
there's still they're going to talk
about it for a long ass time no for sure
like that's always going to be a part of
him
yes he's very lucky that the clip that
came out not that I'm saying that this
is a good situation but he's lucky that
they didn't edit the clip where it was
just him slapping her oh yeah yeah so
now there is this whole idea where I'm
not saying it's right but people are
it's not right well she [ __ ] swung
first yeah because if he didn't have
that part it's just game over he's like
he just assaulted me this could be true
though no 100 I'm just saying that most
people probably would have edit that
part out sure me and Tiff have been
having conversations about it what's up
sorry no me and said we've been having
conversations about it because she's
like that's [ __ ] up that she slapped
him and I was like yeah that's [ __ ] up
he shouldn't have done that but like
she [ __ ] hit him first you know and
then she's like wait would you slap me
and I'm like no I wouldn't slap you yeah
he would but I wonder if you slap me I
would never slap you but at the same
time it's like some people have to
understand
if you're a woman and you hit the wrong
guy yeah they gonna hit you back yeah
this is a reality like if it's not right
by any means but it's just like that's
it some people are crazy some people
will [ __ ] punch you in the face
you've seen videos like that all over
the Internet like that it's weird though
because I saw this video too in New York
where this girl she grabs dog [ __ ] off
the floor and she smeared in a guy's
face and that guy shocked her and then
everybody started jumping the dude and I
was thinking to myself
smeared dog [ __ ] in his face yeah right
so I don't understand how you nobody
decided to pull her away and be like hey
stop this yeah but then this guy gets
dog [ __ ] in his face and then he gets
his ass beat the worst day of my life
dude yeah where'd you see that video I
follow a lot of weird fight videos so
why is this very Niche yeah
my whole Twitter
um timeline that's like his porn that's
what you probably jerked out
if you had 45 minutes to jerk off that's
what you want yeah
that's your creation I don't know why I
fight videos yeah they are good it's
just you just live through the World
Star Hip-Hop has amazing that's what it
is you live through it you know it
reminds it makes me laugh dude he's like
he's getting in love with it and it
makes me laugh because I wish somebody
recorded how bad of a fighter I was when
I was younger I've never seen you touch
his chest I'm so moved serious when I
see things like that it puts in
perspective how a majority of people
fight so I think we get to see the
cleaned up version on UFC yeah but most
people just swing for the [ __ ] fences
right if they're about it and so when we
retell our stories like I've done
multiple times like yeah man I suck this
dude up most likely my wrist was
crowback right and I was doing this yeah
that's not how I remember it sure but
now I look at these videos I'm like I
bet you I look just like in your head
you're Anderson Silva versus Chris
Lehman
you're you're [ __ ] 10-7ing everybody
and then I read the comments and the
comments make me laugh because they go
look at this form this fool can't fight
I'm like you can't fight either worse
right everybody's an expert in fighting
at the end of the day you don't know
what's going to happen you might be
outside of a gym holding somebody down
and just [ __ ] slapping and back and
forth allegedly allegedly not like you
did that but yeah allegedly that might
be happening
three years of kickboxing and the first
thing you do is just [ __ ] paint brush
them yeah yeah like this like
a squishy jacket like Bob Ross cleaning
my paintbrush you know you don't know
what's gonna happen those five videos
make my day I feel really good every
night before I go to sleep I see no
wonder you can't go to sleep bro you
probably hyped up on adrenaline just
watching a bunch of Korean people just
sock each other's faces I noticed that
too like sometimes when I watch fights
and I get two inside like too into it
like my heart rate's racing and I'm just
like up I can't go to sleep also stop
doing that bro especially when you're on
caffeine you're gonna stay up all night
I love it
it makes me and it makes me want to
train again though so like I'll watch
these videos and then literally in the
middle of night at like 10 30. I just
get where are you going don't worry I
have a mission
little Dojo I make and I try to do the
combo that they did and it [ __ ] feels
good yeah whenever I watch UFC fights
one it deters me from fighting ever
again but two it makes me want to train
more yeah it's exciting yeah yeah man I
I think the
what always shocks me too is when I see
somebody do something that I've seen
them train in videos and I see them do
these combos I'm like holy [ __ ] he just
did it in an actual fight yeah whether
it's repetition or whatever the [ __ ] it
is it's ingrained in him yeah like how
the [ __ ] do you decide to just [ __ ]
slip hook dip rotate body head frame
cross what the [ __ ] is that a cow like
it's hard enough to do that on pads
right you know what I'm saying right you
see somebody do it in real life blows my
[ __ ] mind yeah yeah
dude Victoria Lee wow bro oh my God I
just died
she was 18. yeah she was like 17 when
she uh debuted at one Championship she
beat up some like 30 year old woman bro
yeah took her lunch money I think a lot
I think uh they haven't disclosed
officially probably suicide yeah oh
really I think uh what's your sister's
name I can't believe I'm forgetting her
name Angela Angela Angela Lee she's a
beast beast but she posted something and
though at the very end it was like make
sure you check in on Jeff Chan with
boobs
uh crazy
[Laughter]
this is an unfair match that's [ __ ] up
yeah well that's Christian Lee yeah so
Christian Lee just won two belts bro
he's a beast he's [ __ ] nuts and he's
always been a [ __ ] killer dude did
you see him in the beginning of that
fight no he almost got knocked out
rocked so [ __ ] hard it looked like he
was going to be knocked out throughout
the whole round and came back and won by
TKO did one championship fights bro they
got really good fights man like
everyone's like bellators obviously
Bellator is up there but I think one is
the only thing that's contending with
the UFC or striking it is amazing for
pure entertainment purposes and then
they got a bunch of those dagestani guys
who are all habib's dudes Norma they're
actually I think one of them is 155 and
he's gonna fight uh Christian Lee he can
just beat the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] shiny
Aoki and I'm like oh these dagestandis
are gonna it's gonna be a problem so for
for people who are listening out there
the reason why this is such a big deal
so Christian Lee angelili and Victoria
Lee are from a linear they're a family
it's like a family lineage of amazing
Fighters based out of Hawaii christianly
a young Phenom right Angela Lee Young
Phenom all of them the whole family
brother this is his third sister third
sister came in 17 years old the girl
just hit puberty and beat the [ __ ] out
of a mother
for children beat The Living Daylights
out of her right and then out of nowhere
December 26 I believe or like on
Christmas day after Christmas she uh
it's not
confirmed but basically in the way that
she posted is saying like check in on
your family you don't know what they're
going through [ __ ]
100 of suicide so [ __ ] rough dude
this girl at the top of her [ __ ] game
obliterating people highly respected and
she killed herself dude what the [ __ ] is
going on man 2023 is starting off in a
weird [ __ ] way I just think the I was
listening to huberman talk about this
with like Jocko willnick about like
suicide because he was talking about
Draco was talking about
um how a lot of Navy SEALs obviously
through trauma
sometimes like
suicide is pretty prevalent in the Navy
SEAL community and then human was kind
of talking about it and he and he knows
the [ __ ] reason why anybody does
anything you know he's such a smart dude
and he was saying like yeah like I
really don't nerd yeah [ __ ] nerd dude
he's like I really don't know why people
are committing suicide at this rate like
there's really no explanation that I can
think of scientifically biochemistry
wise like why this is happening but a
lot of it was like a lot of people don't
have the right Outlook where they just
they can't see ahead of themselves
enough they don't have the ability to
see ahead of themselves and know that
like what they're feeling and going
through is only temporary like
emotionals emotion feeling is only
doesn't last forever like you'll you'll
see it through and he's saying that like
a lot of people don't have that
foresight and I think that's what causes
them to but it's got to go I mean I
guess yeah but it's just on top of other
things of course because I mean on paper
we can all be like yo pain is temporary
and all that stuff but like people that
like I I can't even imagine because I've
had bad times like I've had shitty
things happen to me and I've been sad
and you know whatever
but I bet you it doesn't even come close
to whatever people that like are on the
verge like I don't even like I don't
know
I don't know what gets them in that
place or how dark it gets but
I mean think about how strong your
survival to live is just as an animal
just as like being an animal as a
fighter as a fighter too yeah a
successful fighter yeah a family of five
the thing is with fighting though like
the CTE has to play into it you know I
mean like there has to be something to
like
you know getting your head rocked a lot
that you know I mean you see it with
football players like it's just
something about your decision making
probably gets [ __ ] up yeah changes
from getting cracked in the head a lot
yeah because sheets
I literally came out of nowhere and also
I don't think she's as public with her
social media and stuff so nobody really
knows her like that
um she literally just came onto the
scene a year ago but you know for I I
mean seemingly it seems like they're
pretty like close-knit family because
they also train together and they were
all blindsided they had no [ __ ] idea
which is going through [ __ ] and I wonder
too for those people out there who kind
of feel like these emotions of
committing suicide and people say just
reach out
um I don't know if somebody reaches out
would they have stopped
when the dancer a twitch oh bro that's a
huge one right I still don't think he
killed himself really uh just a little
odd yeah why
everybody the guy who he was a he was a
huge dance guy he's like a legend in the
dancing he was you know Ellen Degeneres
and he was like dude he had from the
outside looking in you're like this guy
has it all he has a beautiful family you
know not even just outside looking in
people who know him personally I have
friends who know him personally like
just talk to him like a week or two
before he passed away uh and they talk
consistently they're like this doesn't
make any sense there are people who come
like I know who have committed suicide
that I know right where I could kind of
rationally say you know what I could
kind of see what they were going through
yeah not a single person I know that
knows him personally has said that they
go no this doesn't make sense every
single one so I don't want to start a
conspiracy or everything right let the
let the dead rest in peace it just
doesn't sit with me right but isn't that
like so crazy like you've from
everything you've heard about this one
dude it's so like
positive across the board that you can't
even fathom why this dude specifically
get to that point you know for somebody
with you know like Robin Williams when
he passed away it made sense not not
made sense but we could see it yeah
right
um with somebody like him I just don't
like it like none of the pieces add up
even a little bit
um he killed himself at a motel next to
his house like that was walking distance
how like like you know
um and then there was like some weird
like stuff that the uh Motel workers
were saying like we didn't hear anything
crazy or anything else like that certain
things aren't adding up people were
talking the story yeah I don't know
really I don't want to say anything that
I that hasn't been confirmed but it just
doesn't sit really right with me funny
thing enough like I know this is not
funny but I just remember that day when
it happened a bunch of people were
texting me like hey just checking in and
I'm I just wrote back I'm not going to
kill myself shut the [ __ ] up
it was literally I got
I would say 12 texts hey man just want
to say I love you I think that's
[ __ ] or what I just why does
everybody think I'm gonna kill myself
yeah I just texted you yeah I was like
do you you should check in the people
who pretend to be happy yeah yeah I'm
miserable all the time I'm open about it
I'm pretty good you know it's pretty
good I got like 12 texts of like hey bro
just want to let you know man everyone
checked on you name names
you should send them back a picture you
can't name one of them I'm not gonna
name one of them my buddy Josh
that's so funny hit me up because I just
want to say I love you I'm like I'm not
going to kill myself why do you think he
texted you why do you think you got so
many texts out there I think because the
the thing about it is that Comics are
the saddest people ever sure not me I'm
pretty good yeah
yeah that's that's the thing is stunned
around I don't think that's necessarily
true either like they're sad ass Comics
but I don't they're not all I'm pretty
happy yeah I feel good yeah so and then
I think the most annoying thing was when
I kept on receiving text messages from
people I don't like
like I haven't heard from in years do
you feel like they're being insincere
because I feel like 50 of that might be
just like a weird gesture and I listen I
know I shouldn't have texted this back
and it's a joke but once again once I
texted it's already out but somebody
this person who I I literally the last
time I saw this guy I said if you see me
walk the other way because he did some
shady [ __ ] to me
like who the [ __ ] is this person this
guy I'll tell you about it after but
this guy
he texts me and he goes like hey man
just checking in on my friends and I
said listen I wasn't going to kill
myself but I am now
I just feel haha LOL love you bro and I
was like don't love you back why are you
texting me thank you
and then it was just left on red I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you thinking yeah
I don't like you I it's not that ice
maybe you're not mean enough dude I
literally said to him
walk the other way did you see me walk
the other way that's right you gotta you
gotta Come Harder so I saw him and it
gets worse I saw him at this event it
was like this smooging event this is
after the text this is before this was
the last time I saw him oh and he comes
out to me he did some dirty [ __ ] to me
and he just goes hey bro do I haven't
seen you in so long like like I've been
thinking about you I was like that's
funny I haven't thought about you once
why the [ __ ] are you talking to me yeah
yeah and yeah and then he apologizes he
goes yeah I just want to say sorry I was
like no it's been years it's when you
should have apologized was then now it's
too late like I don't like you right and
people know how very sincere I can be
when it comes to emotions like this
because there's no point there's no
point in me seeing him at another event
and pretending like hey bro what's good
I like your shoes
David I can't imagine you doing that
[ __ ] no I like that that's how it should
be and for most people even if I don't
like them I can be cordial with him he
knows I cannot be cordial because in all
honesty I should have knocked his
[ __ ] teeth out can you briefly talk
about what he did so basically what he
did was that he kind of muted like the
Hollywood social media game type of
stuff right so he's he is known as a
habitual person who will step on you to
get what he needs so he owed me uh we
did a project together and he was
supposed to edit and get it done the guy
decides that he found somebody else to
latch onto and then he starts working on
their stuff two months I paid him for
the gig and he just bounced oh you don't
take [ __ ] money and I was broke at
the time yeah he took my livelihood from
me yeah I should have [ __ ] strangled
him and so I found out he's back home or
whatever and I heard he was my friends
were telling me right at his apartment
hit him up and I was like hey so you're
at your house right now people told me
you're at your crib you're back in the
city you either come back to my house in
[ __ ] in two hours let me give you two
hours to come here I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
that's all I said he comes back and he's
just literally crying apologizing I'm so
sorry man and I literally told him like
this is [ __ ] up as a friend we're
doing this business transaction number
one you stole from me like I'm broke I
just came to La I am asked out like
seriously broke eating Top Ramen every
[ __ ] day I got this box spring bed
and then one [ __ ] computer all in my
room and you stole from me and I'm
looking at him I was like how do you
[ __ ] live with yourself and he's just
like no I just got busy I was like
[ __ ] bro I know you're working on
this other guy's project because you
know that he can get you further than I
can you step on people to get where
you're at so get the [ __ ] out of here if
I ever see you again it's on site that's
all I said give me my [ __ ] money back
and then that's the last time I saw
that's wild that he texted you just
checking
that's so wild he's delusional he's he's
mentally ill yeah ruin my whole [ __ ]
day I didn't even know who it was
because it's just a blank [ __ ] number
right wow just checking in on you bro we
love you bro yeah checking in on your
Mentos
[ __ ] yeah what a dumbass that's he's
he's trying to get something out of that
yeah I'm talking pretty wild yeah
a little kid
now [ __ ] that guy 100 can you imagine a
friend doing that to you no like knowing
how like you're barely keeping the
lights on and then stealing my [ __ ] and
walking away with it acting like it's
cool yeah yeah like I wouldn't [ __ ]
find you bro like he's [ __ ] lucky I
am a Christian man yeah yeah Christian
boy you know what's good I was thinking
about this recently it's like a jail is
actually a good thing because jail
prevents me from doing a lot of the
things you know what I mean like a lot
of times I'm like I want to do that but
I will be in jail and then I don't do it
oh let me let me and then you just have
to swallow it so you know how I watch a
lot of fight videos right yeah yeah I
saw this video that traumatized me it
was this very large man that literally
was choking a guy with one hand right
and somebody's recording him in the jail
because they you know they have stolen
phones or [ __ ] or like yeah they make
tick tocks and they're choking he's
choking this guy this guy's maybe six
foot five
300 something pounds and this guy's like
yo get off me [ __ ] get off me
dude's looking around and he starts
[ __ ] grabbing his dick and he goes
and the guy's being choked he goes why
are you grabbing my dick and the guy's
looking around just [ __ ] yanking at
his dick
I was traumatized the worst nightmare of
a sexual assault he said he was looking
around
[ __ ] like those Chinese medicine
balls oh yeah yeah just jostling that
[ __ ] dude and I was shook yeah yeah I
can't believe [ __ ] like that happen if
that guy that's getting choked if he
gets hard is that gay huh
hey you was here at the moment right in
the moment
what if he got soft hands dude if you
swiped his dick right now that [ __ ]
getting hard
it's true dude if that guy's on day 11
yeah dude
the part that made me uncomfortable was
him choking him and then looking around
like this yeah yeah so casual right so
casual yeah and the guy just goes
like the dumbest question in the world
you know yeah you know because he want
that prison slime yeah man you want that
sweet tea baby
you know it's not bad for somebody who's
never kicked no it wasn't he was great
no he looked good he's an athlete I feel
like he's earned everyone's respect it's
hard because he has a lisp and an
underbite so does he yeah if you hear a
promote I'm over here at the pfl
he's gonna have trouble with the
wrestling for sure dude yeah hey bro
guess what though he's the wrestle bro
you didn't know Ohio State oh you're
right better than his brother and and
they they were like Ohio was like the
mecca mecca for wrestling what about
jits though no jits yeah but he'll he'll
be high yeah the wrestling is going to
go a long way well he wants to like Nate
Diaz and I don't think that's what he
wants because if he wants to take it to
the ground Napier's will just [ __ ]
yeah like no jizz even a little jizz is
a [ __ ] you know what that's right
right but that's why he wants to do a
half boxing half MMA that's stupid
though see this is the thing too about
that kid I just don't care for these
matches I want to see him because I
think he's good I think that he can beat
a lot of amateur boxers no problem yeah
and he's getting better too yeah and he
think he cares yeah so for him what I I
guess I don't think a lot of people are
gonna watch even his last boxing match
not a lot of people watch yeah kind of
bombed right who the [ __ ] cares is
Tyrone Woodley's the second fight nobody
[ __ ] watched nobody cares like the
Anderson Silva one not a lot of people
watch that either yeah but I wonder what
would change if he were to fight someone
who's like his age his like skill level
do you think he would get a bump in
pay-per-view do you think he could
attract that or did you think he only
needs to fight retired MMA guys he is
the only draw uh people who are hardcore
MMA fans of Anderson Silva you think
they watched that fight they did not out
of defiance yeah maybe some of them were
just like maybe I want to I didn't watch
it I didn't care to watch it right so I
wasn't sure and I'm uh you know Anderson
Silver my favorite fighter of all time
heartbroken watching that [ __ ] but I
knew he was going to lose because he's
[ __ ] ancient as [ __ ] yeah
um and plus I I looked at his body this
man didn't take roids yeah how come he
didn't just do a little quick a little
bit dog just look at Donald Cerrone
yourself well he's all jacked is it
talking about how he did Donald
cerrone's statement is amazing he goes
I'm on roids now I understand why people
took this stuff I feel like I'm in my
20s again oh really yeah is he he's
retired though now yeah we're tired so
he's just on Roy's yeah he said [ __ ] it
yeah he's like [ __ ] I'm on trt that's
like the new popular thing though trt
the guys hop on trt Joe Rogan on trt
what is that Roy's trt yes it's like a
gray area Instagram but it's it still
probably gets the job when I get older
I'm gonna take trt I started taking trt
at my age really which is nuts really
yeah he's 134. how much are you how much
are you how much are you how much are
you worth how much are you I'm uh 34.
damn my third
he was really young
he was on the juice he was on the south
coast of secret juice I saw him when he
was 34 jacked amazing specimen that was
a specimen he's still young bro
Joe Rogan nah
for you dude boom you two you don't
think so I think I think you would have
a better I mean not me I would get
murdered I'd [ __ ] yeah he's stronger
[ __ ] I heard he's he's kind of
aggroating roles I I could I could
probably imagine I'll grab his ankle
though dude but he's for sure old school
all old school Jitsu from what I heard
is like that though right like they're
all pretty pretty aggressive like they
[ __ ] straight up just go at it yeah
like back in the day type yeah I'm sure
they went hard [ __ ] around bro do you
well you'd be choking people out now for
me yeah I'm saying he don't [ __ ] around
I'm not saying me you're talking around
a little bit it gets mad dude
we always act so interesting I think
it's mad you're talking about dog it's
just it's just turn up the heat that's
all it is and grappling [ __ ]
what timer what timer yeah this is me in
the background time
hey guys take it easy
yeah dude because you'd be accusing me
of going hard and [ __ ] listen my CTE
speaks for itself
no you that's that's fake bro guys I
don't know what I'm talking about
smoking you know I feel praised me to
Allah
I don't think I know guys fighting is so
crazy bro check this out check this out
I this has happened a couple months ago
I was driving and I was like you know
what
I was like I wanna I don't know why I
popped in my head it was [ __ ] sexy
Yama remember sexy oh yeah dude okay his
walk out I was like I want to see his
walk out dude I I watched this walk out
where he's fighting and it's not PRI I
think it's probably I said this to me
yeah I sent it to you it was like Pride
it was something like it was in Japan in
the the fight organization
and the production value is amazing
yeah I think it was right risen or
whatever the [ __ ] fire he comes out to
that famous opera song
dude that's his walkout song right he
comes out with a whole school of kids
and geese bro he comes out he like he
like does this whole thing where he like
bows he gets on his knees and he like
does this whole thing and then at one
point he goes ah he screams I watch this
thing I started crying
[Laughter]
I started like not like hard crying yeah
but my eyes like I got deteriorated what
do you think it was that made you cry
was it the kids no it was your father
now no no no no no that it wasn't that
at all it was what was so sick to me was
like that I started thinking about
fighting in general like how scary it is
dude what it look and also how epic it
was it looked like Dragon Ball Z like it
looked like he was gonna go fight an
alien yeah on behalf of the human race
to fight some green [ __ ] in a
ring dude perfect form just when he
yelled like like that emotion because
like I felt like I've had like the
boxing match of Christos and like on
nowhere near the level of that and I
felt those emotions so I cannot even
imagine how intense though and like the
fact that like you could die it's not
likely that you're gonna die but you
could definitely you could get some
serious like you're putting yourself out
there like that I want you to watch
things made me cry
when he lost to the nurmagomedov and
they recorded him backstage oh bro and
he starts bawling one line he goes I
don't even know why I'm doing this
anymore and that [ __ ] broke my [ __ ]
heart well at the same time you're 40
years old and you're a legend like in my
mind he needs to do this he's like you
don't need to do this anymore yeah but
it's but it's that [ __ ] right it's like
it's that human nature [ __ ] where it's
like especially in Fighters it's like
they want to see they always want to
test themselves and they get so
accustomed of doing it their whole life
because they have to like especially we
have 40 [ __ ] fights on your belt he
got choked out by Mikey
Italian boy yeah
who does Jutsu on the side
it's funny because when he was talking
on Joe Rogan you could tell he's a
little different oh bro he's he's got a
touch of the tizzle yep he definitely
got something and then he's suspectful
he's talking about how he's fluent in
Portuguese and I was like dope so I
looked up a video of him speaking
Portuguese you are not fluent
so I asked um he still sounds Italian so
I asked a couple like one person I know
that speaks Portuguese right and it's a
white girl that learned how to speak
Portuguese and uh she did she was doing
the uh Peace Corps stuff and so I sent
her the video I was like how good is
this Portuguese she goes he sounds
freaking [ __ ]
her words not my worst that's what she
said and I was cracking up I'm like what
don't worry about the accent but is he
fluent she goes no he's not fluent like
he's not fluent at all but when he was
talking on the Rogan podcast he was
talking like he's out here like okay
oh my God yeah
Arizona
[Music]
but apparently like his Portuguese is
really not that good yeah but he can get
by with it yeah you know so that's funny
he's like he's fluent yeah he said he
was David wasn't calling him out of the
receipts I also called him out foreign
he's a thing for Fighters if you're calm
like that was an Anderson Anderson Silva
thing like he could enter the Flow State
real quick like that calmness is just
is a classic example of just his age
caught up to him yeah because what made
him great was his reaction time and his
counters just that one millisecond off
and he's getting caught so it's just him
moving back perfect but not fast enough
not fast enough and it just gets clipped
yeah time man yeah it's his age that's
all that it is just take some steroids
please maybe take them I wish he would
have just gone on a quick regimen and
then people have been like you never get
the fight again I don't care I got to
see old Anderson again dude yeah Jake
Paul should fight [ __ ] Vitor belt for
bro yeah he's on all the Jews he on all
the steroids yeah and he's good on the
roids baby oh he's monstrous he might be
the best you might be the best he's the
alien that [ __ ] sexy Yama was gonna
fight for the world dude
in the final form that's final form self
did you see Evander Holyfield and Vitor
belt for the Box oh no I didn't I saw
that yeah I did see that dog that [ __ ]
broke my heart man beat the [ __ ] out of
Evander Evander Holyfield fights he
looks like old like young Evander
Holyfield physically yeah but he moves
like he's 90. yeah he's old man he
definitely has CTE he has something with
him but something's off because he's so
sorry bro these poor Fighters getting
exploited out here man and also that's I
think that's the thing I don't like it's
white beat up our Legends oh like let
them live as Legends they are [ __ ] at
the tail end of their [ __ ] life if
you want to lose unfortunately in the
fight game the Legends have the name
recognition and that becomes [ __ ]
like it just becomes a jumping off point
for younger fighters right yeah anybody
that wants to make a name like because
Vitor belt for it no matter what nobody
can take that away from him no matter
what with all the asterisks that are
next to that Victory he could always
tell people yeah I knocked out Vander
Holt yeah at the senior citizen home
in the boxing match but Tyson looked
good though when he fought uh I think
Tyson might be doing a little bit of oh
he might be yeah
I don't mind it I love it I love it it
look good you don't think I'll come here
and just be ethereal you don't think
I'll [ __ ] be here I sting like a horn
and a Japanese hornet because it's so
much dangerous why didn't anyone ask me
if I'm hurt when I got hit in the face
that's the he was like he's actually his
feelings are hurt yeah how come nobody
cares about me I'm an animal but I have
a heart
so that's really good thank you I
listened to a lot of Mike Tyson yeah I
like I love listening to Tyson get mad
at people in interviews when they think
it's a joke but he's gonna happen out of
nowhere too it happens it's just like
Vlad TV interview flat TV the the blonde
dude yeah no Vlad TV is the uh he does
he's the dweeb who does the uh hip-hop
interviews oh I don't think I've seen
him yeah he'll have Aries Spears on or
whatever whatnot but he's annoying but
he gets a lot of great guests so Mike
Tyson was on he goes hey so you like he
goes this is his voice by the way exact
so you like being around uh he sounds
like George uh from tigerbelly Eagles so
you like being around a lot of dangerous
people huh uh you like surrounding
yourself around danger and then Mike
Tyson goes
that's a bad question you think I like
being around precarious people
you think I like being around people who
have just questionable backgrounds is
that what you saying about me huh and
that he's just sitting there just
stuttering no what I'm saying is like I
think that uh you know the people that
you choose to be around is just a little
dangerous so you say I may put Life
Choices huh and then he's getting pissed
taking himself in a hole that's funny I
I get scared through the screen yeah and
he's not gonna hurt me like when when uh
Joe Rogan was laughing at something Mike
Tyson said oh yeah it's cracking up he
goes I'm serious I'm not making a joke
yeah and then Joe Rogan yeah I
understand what you're saying
he's probably so big too
I get it I get it yep yep I understand
he stopped laughing immediately dude if
you were high and you're talking to
Tyson and he got mad at you bro oh
that's got to be the worst did you see
the Habib interview with Mike Tyson I
saw clips of it yeah because it was kind
of awkward because uh they ask him like
who's your favorite boxer of all time
and he looks at Mike Tyson he goes like
no offense Mike but like Muhammad Ali is
my favorite and he kind of like
and he's like because the Dage standings
are so matter of fact of how they speak
he kind of like dunks on Mike Tyson a
little bit and saying like yeah like
kind of breaks him down like uh you
weren't really the most technical I
don't really like your style but like
like you're great but like Muhammad Ali
is my favorite and it was like you kind
of feel awkward a little bit but then
also Mike Tyson was so [ __ ] baked
that he even know what planet he was
like he couldn't even do the interview
bro crazy Mr unicorn
that's crazy
I don't care what anybody you can never
look at Mike Tyson say he wasn't
technical he was so technical his
technique is uh and amazing and his
footwork was amazing his footwork is
crazy he was constantly like if you're
here he was always like this right and
he made his build work right for for
that division he's a heavyweight he's
six foot one yeah bro no he was very
technical it was crazy too because when
I was thinking about how he's doing like
oh people could probably you know keep
the distance and you know frame off him
a little bit his footwork was too ahead
of you in this earlier stage before you
know started going through his problems
for sure but people were constantly you
know long guard trying to frame him off
his [ __ ] jab spiraled upwards you
couldn't see it it was such a weird
style he was like constantly moving to
get in on you and then like there's even
clips of him like where he's weaving and
he's literally like almost his chin is
almost touching the floor yeah the guy's
swinging at him he's like literally
almost laying down on the on the canvas
dodging punches comes up and then cracks
the deal like crazy and I I kind of
realized how well I mean obviously you
could see him and realize how athletic
he is but
um I saw a couple of clips of his
tutorials and I was trying to do what he
does just something simple right just
throwing a straight jab leaning off and
then corkscrewing another jab up is hard
it's exhausting especially with the
speed that he does exactly my [ __ ] was
slow as [ __ ] yeah like there's no way
you could execute that if you're slow
you have to be fast and so like when I
saw him do that he's doing it multiple
times that's like his [ __ ] and he
corkscrews up and then he'll dip he'll
reposition himself throw the up lead
uppercut wrap it backwards oh yeah he's
just doing that with his lead like how
do you do that [ __ ] such a beast [ __ ]
you I wish you two could do that to each
other right now I'm done [ __ ] boxing
bro I love watching YouTube fight it's
it's [ __ ] two brothers
letting out their love and their anger
you know what I mean I [ __ ] love you
I love you too well guess what you're
not gonna have teeth tomorrow
yeah dude you [ __ ] get off on it I
love it I like I do like spraying you
though you like spiders too because it's
funny that's why I like going like long
rounds because it's just fun it is fun
and there's different like beats in the
spying around I love it they're hard to
hit your head moving really good too bro
you hard to hit two [ __ ] what's up yeah
there we go
it's the most entertaining thing for me
it makes me really happy guys it's like
I get to watch the street fights in
person yeah yeah you're like Jester you
know you're like King you're like
YouTube fight you and you you who's next
who wants to box Alex for 10 seconds
that's a scary ten seconds though yes it
is a hurricane if Alex ever got his
cardio up he'd be a [ __ ] world beater
bro yeah he just feels different he hits
hard dude he's strong it's like fighting
a car dude it really is yeah you feel
like E Honda in the street fighter yeah
but I'm not doing any damage and you
tell me right now you don't spray that
full green it's not like Blanca from
[ __ ] Street Fighter yeah yeah he
looks like a green buff in a square yeah
or he's like Zangief but way shorter
yeah no beard
it's so funny too together at um at the
gym yeah I put up and then we're doing
weights and [ __ ] and he forgets that you
know I'm a human nah he knows he likes
to make people feel bad he's always
throwing my face like oh you're only
doing one play that's crazy like I'm
gonna do seven you were doing uh like
[ __ ] you Alex you piece of [ __ ] we were
doing a lap pull Downs with the straight
bar standing yeah and this will you know
he's pulling it like exactly nothing and
I wasn't paying attention to the weight
yeah tell me why I pulled that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] carried me up like this
oh my God I'm like Alex I'm a person
dude I can't do this yeah dude that's a
hard workout too that's why you can't go
like for me either like it's hard to go
heavy on that one like where you go
straight down like that oh yeah straight
[ __ ] he does it it looks like there's
no weights on it you see how big his
[ __ ] lats are he's big he's so strong
big boy [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like the
thing he's a Fantastic Four dude he's a
thing here's the thing just with better
skin
show me your things well this wraps up
this episode of The Genius brain podcast
everybody every Sundays at 12 p.m you
can find Nick the ear nte strong baby
yeah get get that workout and then we
have Pat tisimo at Patrick dot T dot
Riley check him out on his Instagram
just [ __ ] being a poor poor father
my favorite
Sunday's at 12 people